hi everyone thank you for your interest
in hard work I am sergeant from
University of Victoria and this is Joint
work with Paul Beam at University of
Washington uh this talk is about lifting
theorems which are a powerful tool and
theoretical CS which has led to
breakthrough results in many adjacent
areas like Game Theory coin Computing uh
linear programming Etc today's talk in
today's talk we're going to talk about
uh the pursuit of quantitatively
improving these lifting theorems so that
we can get further breakthroughs in
these areas
okay
lifting theorems as the name such as
lift results from a weak model of
computation to a strong model of
computation
so here is a weak model of computation
that's used in uh standard lifting
current system model of decision trees
decision trees are a simple model but
which are powerful enough to capture
many revolutionary algorithms in areas
like learning algorithms or Quantum
algorithms so they are a simple but
powerful
and in this model you're allowed to you
don't have the access you don't have an
unhinted access to the input but you can
only access the inputs bit by bit by
querying them so here is a decision tree
Computing the standard odd function
which is one or functional two bits
which is one if one of the two bits is a
one and it's zero if both of them are
zero
so the decision tree queries uh
variables and then compute science
events no sense
and a lifting theorem translates uh
lower bounds about a function being
computed in in such a weak model like
decision tree into a powerful model of
computation usually this is a powerful
Model A computational is the standard
two-party communication complexity model
that you may be familiar with so in this
setting there are two players Alice and
Bob each have their own individual
inputs X and Y Alice cannot see what Bob
has Dallas doesn't know why so Bob and
similarly popped as in X and they want
to come compute some function pre-agreed
function of their inputs f of x y and
the goal is to communicate as few bits
as possible between them to compute the
value of x y
and uh
another uh the strong model of
computation that one might consider are
decision tree with more complex queries
so here you can consider here we have
the example of parity decision trees
so in parity decision trees uh instead
of
having queries to individual bits you
can have queries to a bunch of inputs
queries which ask for the parity of a
subset of input bits so here example
here uh the parity decision three at the
root queries the parity of C1 C5 and C8
Stanford you get just reveals the parity
it doesn't tell you what z1c5 or C8 is
but it tells you the parity so this is a
more uh powerful model in because trying
to figure out the parity in the decision
tree model would require you to query
but like to query all C1 C5 and C8
to talk more about lifting theorems I'd
like to introduce some uh an important
operation of Boolean functions known as
block composition it is a simple
operation it involves two Boolean
functions let's say F which is on n Bits
and G which is an M bit the composition
the block composition of f and g denoted
by F Circle C is a Boolean function
which takes NM bits of input and
produces one bits of
the precise definition of this lock
conversation will decorate to the next
slide but its connection to lifting the
Ramses as follows so lifting theorems as
we said uh translate lower bonds from a
weak model of computation to a strong
model of computation
so
what it does is that it takes uh lower
bonds about a specific function f in the
weak model of computation let's say
decision tree model and then it would
translate it into low bounds about the
block compose function f compose G in
the strong model of computation let's
say communication complexity and the
power of lifting theorems is that like
once you prove a lifting theorem it's
usually for a specific well-crafted G
but it works for any function f so once
you have a lifting theorem for a
specific Jeep it works with any function
f so you have lower bonds for of f it
automatically translates lower bonds for
f compose C into struct model
and uh and this this function G is which
is carefully Json it's known as the
gadget
okay so let's talk about block
composition in a more detailed manner so
here I'd like to talk about bucker
position in the setting of communication
complexity so in the setting of
communication complexity the F you have
is uh you want to translate uh the lower
bounds on a standard Boolean function f
in the decision model to lower bound
support a two-party function f compose G
but in the two part so F let's say it's
on n Bits and it takes inputs Z1 to z n
then we need we take g to p like a two
party function so there's a natural
partition of Json puts into Alice's
parts and Bob spots so here if you look
at the first copy of G it takes X1 so X1
is Alice's input and takes y1 which is
prompted so G is a communic it's a
function and a communication setting f
is a function and uh
the standard like decision trees setting
so and how do you define F compose C so
you take the ith input of f let's say z
i and Define it to be the output of G
applied on x i and y i okay so this is
the natural definition that I was
talking about in the earlier slide
and this is a very natural definition
for uh for many reasons one of the
reasons is that like many interesting
functions that you want to understand in
the setting of communication complexity
uh can be written as
a block composition for example one of
this
one of the more prominent functions
which are used in many applications of
communication complexities the
disjointers function or its complement
setting Test Section function here Alice
and Bob are given uh characteristic
vectors of two sides and they want to
know if they set up an intersection this
can be naturally written as the block
composition of the standard or function
on n Bits with and functional to bits in
The Following sets
X1 to xn and Bob has inputs y1 to y n
and x i is 1 if Alice's set has this
element I and Y is 1 if Bob's in set has
the element I so there's its intersect
if there's some index I in N where x i
and y I are both one so this and uh so
if they do indesit one of these ants
will turn on and when the output of an
and S1 the uh the output of the r
naturally becomes one so this this
naturally computes the set intersection
function so just recall many interesting
functions can be written as natural
block conversations so to summarize
lifting theorems are theorems which work
for a specific Gadget G and for all
functions F which essentially say that
the communication complexity of the
block compose function f compose C is
approximately equal to the decision tree
complexity of f
uh and if we are considering the lifting
from query complexity to to party
communication complexity
and the Holy Grail here is to get
gadgets which are as small as possible
ideally we'd like to get gadgets which
are just constant size
and lifting theorems Have Been
instrumental in solving long-standing
open problems in many areas like
combinator and optimization
communication complexity improve
complexity circuit complexity Game
Theory Etc
so in this slide I want to talk about
frontiers of Shifting theorems so the
main overhead in lifting theorems is the
Gadget size so recall that lifting
theorem strands for lower bonds for a
function f on n Bits to a function f
compose t on NM bits so ideally we want
to keep the M of the gadget as small as
possible and the Holy Grail in this
direction is to get M constant but even
getting M to be substantially smaller
than what is known would result in
breakthrough result and results in
circuit complexity prove complexity Etc
and these are on problems which have
been open for a very long time and
they're really hard problems
so here's a quick overview of our
results so our first result shows that
currently known techniques cannot reduce
Gadget size to even to constant for
General lifting theorems we actually
prove something stronger we show that
even going Beyond below login is not
possible with current techniques uh for
General lifting tables
nonetheless we show that if you want to
prove lifting terms which lift uh
decision tree complexity to uh somewhat
stronger models maybe something not
something as strong as two-party
communication complexity but a stronger
model like parity decision trees you can
get a lifting theorem with uh with the
constant size Gadget we prove a lifting
theorem with conscious gadgets from
decision tree simple decision tree
complexity to parity decision we show
that decision tree depth this decision
tree depth can be lifted to parity
decision tree right and similarly
decision tree size can be lifted to
parakeet is essential size
and uh this result this lifting theorem
has interesting consequences in proof
complexity using this result we actually
show that tree resolution proof size can
be lifted to tree respiratory proof size
we'll talk in detail about what these
proof systems are in the latest slides
so what do we mean by current techniques
so
we we
use this to refer to simulation based
approaches for proving lifting terms so
what are simulation based approaches to
proving lifting theorems so usually in a
simulation based approach a query to
communication lifting theorem is proved
in two steps the first step is the easy
Direction and the second step is the
harder Direction which is known as the
simulation theorem so in the first step
it shows that the communication
complexity of the lifted function has
composed C is upper bounded by the
decision tree complexity FF time
segmentation conductivity this
essentially says that if you have a
efficient decision tree Computing F you
can turn that into an efficient
communication protocol Computing Flex G
the idea is fairly straightforward so
Alice and Bob want to simulate the
decision tree Computing F to come up
with a communication protocol Computing
F conversely so here let's say this is
the decision tree Computing f it queries
the variables even but Alice and Bob has
no clue about the value of C1 so they
need to know the query answer to Z1 to
proceed along this decision tree but
they know that Z1 is the result of
applying the two party function G on X1
and Y One X minus Alice is first input
and Y one is Bob's first little bit so
they can compute the value of G of X1 y1
using the best protocol for uh
communication protocol for G using just
c c of G pitch so by just exchanging
ccog pets they can figure out the value
receivable and based on the value of Z1
let's say it's 0 they continue the
simulation and go down to the next node
in the decision tree and then it's C2
they know they don't know what is the
value C2 but they know that Z2 is G
apply to X2 Y2 so they similarly land
the protocol for G again so on and so
forth until they come to an answer
and the cost of doing the simulation is
uh just the decision tree complexity of
f which is the number of queries you
make on the path times the communication
complexity so this is a this is the easy
Direction so in the hard Direction what
you want to say is in the reverse
Direction so first you have an efficient
critical communication critical solving
F compose G then you want to use that to
come up with a decision tree
Computing F whose query complexity is
related to the communication competition
with compost C divided by ccog so this
is usually done by designing a meta
algorithmic recipe which takes an
arbitrary protocol that solves F
compulsory which is somewhat efficient
and uses that to come up with a decision
tree Computing f
so the simulation uh the high level idea
behind the simulation SS followers so we
start with a protocol Pi solving as
compost C given on the left and we use
that to come up with the design a
decision tree for f on the right
so we start uh at the root of the
protocol initially at the root of the
protocol there players haven't spoken
anything so they know they don't know
anything about any of their inputs but
after communicating for a few rounds
Alice and Bob might learn
a good good amount of information about
some of their inputs let's say in this
point we are in the simulation and in
the simulation we are going to trace a
path from root to one of the leaves
and let's say we are at a node where
Alice and Bob has learned quite a lot
about X3 and Y3
but it's not all the information but
they've learned just enough information
at that point in the simulation theorem
we would query the variable C3
so before uh they learn
enough information about X3 and Y3 to
decide whether what is the value of C3
we would just query Z3 at this important
threshold
and based on the query answer that we
get we'll continue the simulation and
until another unless some other variable
set of variables become revealed in
terms of amount of information Alice and
Bob the slide at that point we query
that variable we continue the simulation
until we get to a leaf node of the
protocol
and at the leaf not the protocol the
players know the value that's compose G
and looking at that value we can come we
can decide the value of f for the
decision tree
so this is a high level idea behind
simulation
to carry out such a simulation we need
to maintain a set of ingredients
so
at any point and so what are we doing in
the simulation we are trying to trace a
path from root to one of the leaves so
as to compute the value of f consistent
with the query answers that we have
gotten so far right so at any point in
the simulation we maintain a set of
inputs of Alice and pop
denoted let here by the set curly X and
set curly y
and we're going to maintain some
invariance for this set of inputs so the
first is a very natural invariant it's
we call it the fixed coordinate
invariant which is that like so far in
the simulation we have queried a bunch
of
input variables let's say Z1 C2 and C5
so we want to make sure that the set of
inputs that we are currently keeping
track are consistent with the query
answer that we have gotten so
here we denote I to uh
denote the already queried coordinates
and we want to ensure this consistency
constraint that if you look at the set
of inputs that we are maintaining and
you look at the gadget output on those
coordinates I which have been queried
the the and the value of the gadget is
consistent of the query answer
the other property known as a dispersive
property is the more important one and
this ensures that like uh for the
remaining coordinates which are
unqueried at this point the players do
not know uh
anything on whether Z is one or zero so
for the remaining coordinates we have to
maintain all possible uh future query
answers so we're going to say that this
set of inputs X and Y are so rich so
that if you look at the gadget output
and the remaining unqueried coordinates
they give you all possible zero one
strings of that length
and to maintain this invariance
specially to maintain the dispersive
property we need to do some bookkeeping
so we as we go along in the simulation
We'll add new coordinates to this query
it coordinates and do some cleaning up
to make sure that everything is nice and
tidy
uh just a quick note here that if you're
approving lifting theorems for
randomized in the setting of randomized
algorithms you need a stronger property
known as the extractive property instead
of the dispersive property but here we
are focusing on deterministic lifting
distance
so let me tell you a bit about what this
nice uh measures
that we were talking about in the last
slide which ensure that the gadget has
the dispersal property so
historically even the first nice
measures that was used to ensure
dispersed property for the index Gadget
was the average degree it's used in the
original paper of Russ and McKenzie who
proved a lifting the amendment as a
consequence got uh separation of the
Monitor and say hierarchy but it was
already known that like this uh approach
based on average degree can only give
you linear size index gadgets the other
two measures which are usually used in
common in combination are the
information theoretic measures of main
entropy and deficiency
so
if they get the this the dispersive
property is also a function of the
gadget and not just the nice properties
a nice structures nice meshes so we
introduce the two uh gadgets
which are very commonly used in lifting
theorems so one is the index Gadget and
the other is the inner product Gadget
index Gadget as a gadget where Alice
gets an
pointed which is a value in 1 to M and
Bob gets a Memory Bank of M locations
which we think of as a binary string in
0 1 to the m in the output of the index
Gadget at X comma Y is just the value y
has locate it has at location X so
whatever Alice is pointing to in Bob's
input is the value of the output of the
index Gadget
and the communication complexity and
index Gadget is log m
similarly another very uh popular uh
Gadget is the inner planet Gadget so
Alice and Bob get two B bit strings X
and I and the output of the gadget is
just simply the inner product of X and Y
over F2 and the communication complexity
of the gadget is exactly equals to it
input length
another interesting thing about you know
index Gadget is that it's a universal
Gadget so if you think of Y as a two
table of a log amp bits function then
you can encode any function as a
specific index of X and Y where Y is set
to be the two table of that function
so let's revisit nice measures with
respect to index and in the product
gadgets we already uh mentioned that
average degree cannot give you lifting
theorems for in in index or less than uh
linear size gadgets but for many entropy
and deficiency the current best gadget
sizes are followed as follows so for
index we can already get M to be
something close to linear something like
n log n so this was
in the paper of lmm and pze in itcs last
year and for inner product it's in all
the results from cklm in from CCC 2019
and for inner product it's around Theta
of login
and for index it's almost linear
and even reducing uh the Gadget size for
index from almost linear to poly
logarithmic would lead to breakthrough
results and and these are this would be
particular results and circuit
complexity and proof complexity for a
really big open problems
okay so towards this uh goal of reducing
the Gadget size and how the current
techniques were like low weight mechanic
merge with actually sang in
their paper in itcs so you need to make
the following Construction
uh about the dispersive property of
index
they conjecture that
that there exists
for sufficiently large m
for every X and Y which is deficiency
very small at most some
Delta
they they conjecture that this index is
a good this person in the sense that it
index on such inputs X and Y uh would
contain a sub cube of co-dimension C
Delta
so there's some set of coordinates
I which is at most C Delta
in size which if you exclude them the
index produces every possible binary
string so this is what it means is say
that index contains of cube or code
elemention see that and this is the
dispersive property of State schedule
say our first result proves that there's
this first second gesture for index m is
false as long as m is less than log n
minus Omega 1.
and it also fails for interpreted gadget
for the same kind of range so as long as
you have an India in independent Gadget
uh of size pulp is less than log n minus
Omega n this this was the properties no
longer true
so this shows that the lifting theorems
for inner product gadgets using current
techniques is types in in terms of the
Gadget size parameter so because we
already know uh
lifting theorems for in in a product
with the Theta of login size gadgets and
results prove that
the current techniques cannot improve it
beyond that asymptotically beyond that
okay
we also actually going Beyond we also
prove a deterministic listening theorem
for the index Gadget with constant size
despite proving that the current
techniques cannot improve it even to sub
logarithmic uh
but we proved we achieved this by uh
proving lifting currents for a weaker
class of protocols known as
semi-structured protocols so what is
study structured protocols these are
protocols where Bob can only communicate
priorities of a circuit okay
so given a Boolean function uh
F so using this lifting theorem we prove
the following result given a Boolean
function F1 inputs we come up with an
composed function f Dash by composing f
with an index gadget on constant size
and proved that the decision tree
complexity parity decision tree
complexity FF is tight in terms of the
decision tree complexity of F and the
and this decision tree complexity can be
either the decision tree depth which is
DTR denoted by ddr5 or it could be
decision tree size which is denoted by
size table
independent work by chapter one day and
Monday is Sharif
also proves the same results on parity
decision trees and uh you can listen to
the next talk to know uh more about
their results
okay
so using this lifting theorem we get the
following consequences and proof
complexity so we consider as cluster
proof systems known as risk parity
groups they're also known as wrestling
tubules which introduced by its skin and
circle of in 2014 and they put Globe
once in 2020 so
um
in in a respiratory proof each line in
the proof is a fine Subspace of
uh the space F2 to the n and the
inference rule just says that if you
have a and b you can derive C if C is in
the is a subset of a On A and B
so if
A and B are defined some spaces and C is
another defines the space
and the goal is to derive F2 to that
using our lifting area
protocols we will show that tree rest
size for a formula fee can be lift it to
three rest parity size for a female
formula V Dash where V Dash is obtained
by composing this unsatisfiable case in
F of e with an index Gadget of constant
size
all right
I'd like to conclude the talk with a few
uh future directions
so our resource essentially showed that
nice distributions and our mini entropy
rate it's simple information such as
liquidatory rate it's not the way
forward if you want to improve catch
exercises in the existing simulation
framework
so in the counter example that we
construct it has this very peculiar
structure that a few blocks of box
inputs have only zeros or only once so
one way to avoid such count like maybe
uh
pathological counter examples would be
to consider inputs where every block of
Bob has an equal number of zeros and
ones and once you have such a set of
input we can see restrict uh the events
you maintain such a set of inputs and
assimilation theorem are counter
examples no longer works and we don't
know how to like disprove the contextual
with such set of inputs
the other revenue is that okay so
currently there's this gap between uh
hurt the known limitations of
this is called the lockstone where you
might be able to prove interesting this
elsewhere there are no known limitations
for current techniques which is and
which is a range of M between n which is
almost linear to n log n so can you
prove a lifting theorem with m equal to
Theta and that's an interesting local
problem the other thing is that a lot of
these improvements and recent
improvements in index Gadget size came
from connection to sunflowers so can we
like utilize this connection further to
say maybe something about impossibility
of improving the Gadget size r
improving it further
and in this paper we proved a tree
constants lifting theorem with constant
size gadgets uh for tree-like protocols
but this is other notion of tagged like
criticals where it has more applications
and proof complexity and maybe you can
prove tag like lifting for strictly
protocols that's another interesting
menu
um other other options to consider is
that here we considered semi-structured
critical so it was limited in the sense
that Bob could only send parities so
instead of parities you could consider
other functions which are limited like
majority or other threshold functions
and we do not know anything in this
regime and this might have like like
considering an appropriate uh
restricted functional family like
thresholds to functions or majorities
yeah
you'd be able to get interesting results
improve complexity
that's the end of the talk thank you
everyone and if you have any questions
or comments please feel free to email
either of
us.edu thank you